what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so the omega-level mutant series proved
itself to be really popular I mean you
guys really really seemed to like the
idea of talking about omega-level mutant
Saviano make a little mutants and so on
but there's a problem with that series
all right the first is that it can finds
us two mutants we can't have a series
called omega-level mutants and then talk
about like The Incredible Hulk right I
mean it doesn't make any sense and so
the other problem is that it can finds
us two Marvel comics because again we
can't we can't call a series on mega
level mutants and then talk about the
powers of Superman 1 million and so
we're gonna keep the title of the of
those previous videos the same but I'm
gonna dip my toe in the waters of
changing the title and calling it like
the most powerful beings and comics or
something like that and in this video
we're gonna be talking about Doctor
Strange now those of you guys who are
well-versed in the history of Doctor
Strange know exactly what I'm going to
say so bear with me for a second because
there are a lot of people out there that
don't know about the whole dichotomies
between Doctor Strange the way he used
to be and the way he is now so the
old-school Doctor Strange is referred to
as classic Doctor Strange the modern
Doctor Strange is referred to as just
that modern Doctor Strange classic
Doctor Strange is when he was at his
most powerful um it was stupid how
powerful he was it was insane the kind
of feats that he was able to accomplish
and we'll get into some of those as we
go through this video but on the whole
regardless of you know whether it's
classic or whether it's modern Doctor
Strange his powers usually all derive
from the same location now there are a
couple things that I do want to touch on
here for example the first thing is
what's called a dark hold those of you
guys who are currently watching agents
of shield the dark hold is a huge part
of the story right now ideals of Ghost
Rider and so on and so forth and of
course Robbie ray is the same things
about how he sold his soul to the devil
and so on the dark hold is basically
just like a book of black magic that's
really all it is it's just a book that
deals strictly with black magic Doctor
Strange deals with white magic the good
stuff he doesn't deal with the evil
black magic stuff and so um the dark
hold is largely synonymous with a being
named C'thun which is one of the dark
entities one of the evil
he's out there in the Marvel Universe
it's also been used by Mephisto from
time to time so that's one of the
reasons why a lot of people who were
talking about agents of shield right now
especially myself are saying that we
either we're gonna see we're gonna see
the dark hole in the rock I guess we're
gonna seek a phone or we're gonna see
Mephisto it's one of the other reasons
why people are speculating about
Sigourney Weaver being the main villain
for the defenders TV show on Netflix
that she's gonna play the role of like
like Mephisto or something along those
lines because Mephisto shows up as
either a man or a woman and he does
exist to trick people into giving him
his souls so that's why it all kind of
feeds back into you know Robby Reyes and
Ghost Rider and defenders and Darkhold
and so on and so forth having said all
that let's jump into Doctor Strange
that's what we're here for
so when it comes to Doctor Strange
himself he's not a mutant all right so
his powers aren't part and parcel to
himself so he's not like Professor X
where Professor X had an X gene that
activated and it granted him the power
of telepathy he's not like Cyclops where
his X gene activated and his eyes went
from being normal eyes to being portals
to a dimension made of energy that
allows him to disperse that energy in
the form of optic beams dr. Strange's
powers are actually lent to him by other
people and that's somebody I'd like you
to keep in mind because over the course
of this video we will get into why it is
that he lost his powers why he was D
powered why they made him weaker than he
was the idea of powers being lent to him
will be a major focus of that but among
the core attributes among the core
sources of the magic that he uses is
really the crux of everything which
comes in the form of the book of the
shanthi and I am 100% sure we are going
to see this in the movie if we don't I
will be severely disappointed so long
long ago way back when if we take an
adventure back in time there were
basically the Elder Gods and the Elder
Gods were like the first gods on earth
somebody keep in mind here is that in
the Marvel pantheon of gods you have the
second generation of gods which is like
Odin and that's where you get Zeus and
stuff like that Vishnu that is the in
Marvel Comics representation of the
various gods that people think of right
now when it comes to different religions
the Elder Gods were basically beings
that went crazy with power in response
the representation of Mother Earth a
woman named Gaia the basically summoned
the sentience of the planet that
sentience destroyed all these other gods
and then flew off and merge with the Sun
it sounds crazy and it is crazy but
that's basically what happened with
but while those elder gods were going
crazy and they were you know fighting
each other and consuming each other and
so on one of them had basically taken
off before that war started and this
God's name was Oscar a nosh tour took
off to the furthest reaches of space and
began exploring around just wanting to
learn about the universe but Ashtoreth
also used you know her involvement with
being an elder god to expand her own
knowledge of magic but during this time
Oscar came into contact with the god of
an alien race named hogatha
and in response the two of them realized
that their ideas were one of the same
that they both just wanted to study
magic and see how far they could push
their knowledge and so the two of them
joined forces and then came back to
earth but when they got here Austria
realized that all the Elder Gods had
been destroyed and so Oscar in response
gave birth to automotive now agamotto
is for all intents and purposes the
first sorcerer supreme so for those of
you guys who wonder where the lineage of
that line you know began at it basically
began at automotive and the reason why I
say automotive was effectively the first
sorcerer supreme is because unlike Ash
Tour unlike hogatha agamotto had more of
a hands-on approach when it came to
people it began going through and
teaching various forms of magic more or
less taking on a student of its own
which handed those teeth those teachings
down creating the line of succession for
the mantle of sorcerer supreme but in
addition to this this more hands-on
approach Okimoto
I guess ash tore and hogatha began to
record their knowledge of magic in a
book called the book of a Shanthi and so
that's why this is more or less an
encyclopedia of magic in Marvel Comics
that's where dr. strange derives all of
its knowledge from now there are also
other places where dr. strange gets his
magic for example around a thousand
years prior to the current day there
were a group of eight God's called the
octet sense and they were eventually
banished from earth but the idea was
that they had all competed to see which
one of them was going to be the
strongest which of which one of them had
the most had the greatest amount of
power but because they were banished
from earth what they did is they created
artifacts that were placed on earth and
when the first of these artifacts was
picked up it would in turn create a
trance and seven other human beings
around the world they would go pick out
these artifacts and then they would each
create their own army and the armies
would wage war against each other and
whoever
one would be the you know the I guess
the representation of that particular
God and that God would have won the
contest it was called the octet since
it's kind of a weird situation one of
these gods was a guy named Sid Iraq now
Sid Iraq may sound familiar to you all
if you're familiar with the juggernaut
and the reason why is because the
artifact that he had placed on earth was
the crimson gem which was picked up by
hey Marco which began the octet since
but Cain Marko Hughes that crimson Jim
to become the juggernaut now what dr.
strange uses are called the crimson
bands of cyttorak it's not like the gym
it doesn't grant dr. strange incredible
strength and momentum that can't be
stopped
instead it basically binds people and
they can't escape because this is just
one of the things that they use another
member of the octet since was a guy
named watoomb and dr. strange has what's
called the wand of watoomb this just
shows you how all these different
entities dr. strange borrows powers from
her borrows magic from in some former
fashion he has for example the cloak of
levitation which allows him to fly like
25 miles an hour or something like that
but dr. strange almost never really uses
the cloak of levitation to fly or the
reason being and because he can just
teleport and that's one of the powers
that he gets from the book of the shanti
but he also has different artifacts like
the eye of agamotto
which allows him to see into everything
I mean it you know it allows him to see
into other dimensions it allows him to
see everything that's going on and the
entirety of the multiverse whenever it
is that he happens to be looking into
the eye it's like a crystal ball for
everything in existence he also has
what's called the Amulet of auger motor
which protects him from black magic and
he's got a host of other things that go
along with that now in terms of his
abilities the things that he was capable
of because Marv Rolla in the 1960s and
70s and 80s and 90s was really just
writing stories that were just
interesting and people who loved cosmic
level stuff the book of a shanti was
effectively a license to let dr. strange
do whatever he wanted to do and that was
that was literally it you know the book
of a shanti gave him the spell to do
whatever he needed to do in any
particular situation regardless of what
that situation was that was one of the
reasons why he was so powerful so during
the events of infinity war for example
as part of the tie-ins a Galactus had
traveled to earth to enlist the help of
dr. strange dr. strange said no and
Galactus said you're going to help me
whether you want to or not and the two
of them fought and dr. strange defeated
him in the end Galactus had to threaten
to destroy the world in order to get dr.
strange to help him and dr. strange
agreed to do that
when dr. strange first met the Living
Tribunal which is a multiversal
construct it's second to the one above
all in terms of power the Living
Tribunal bound dr. strange and a
mystical prison of sorts and dr. strange
freed himself now one of the things here
to keep in mind is this does not mean
that dr. strange is equal in power to
the Living Tribunal it just means he was
able to escape the confines of a living
tribunal if the Living Tribunal decided
to kill dr. strange that he would be
dead and there's no two ways about it
that's just the way it goes but that's
that's the kind of power that dr.
strange had there was an instance where
dr. strange wiped out a dimension
because he didn't wanted to exist
anymore I mean these are dr. strange as
the classic dr. strange was the pinnacle
of power I mean he could time-travel he
could see into the future he could alter
reality he could wipe people from
existence I mean he could do everything
he could literally do anything he wanted
to I mean that's the only way I know how
to say it uh he was he was beyond the
power of Franklin Richards in terms of
the things that he could do if that
tells you anything Franklin Richards
madam Jasper's those guys he was well
beyond that
madam Jasper's was like a multiversal
threat although they never really
explored the extent to that dr. strange
in his classic form was definitely a
multiversal threat he could have wiped
out all existence across the multiverse
if each other if he so choose to because
I'm sure there was a spell somewhere
that would let him do that and so the
problem with dr. strange is comics is it
created the Superman complex how do you
beat a guy who can do anything how do
you beat a guy for example who stood
against Adam warlock when he had the
Infinity Gauntlet yes he did that during
the infinity war storyline dr. strange
had to summon the totality of all of his
power every single artifact every iota
of magic in order to stand toe-to-toe
against Adam warlock when he had the
infinity gone it lasted for the blink of
an eye it was super fast and it was only
momentarily enough to you know serve as
a distraction but he did that like it is
it's one of the most insane displays of
magic but because of the fact that
Marvel just really couldn't write
stories that centred on him that were
compelling because he could do
everything it resulted in his comics
being canceled constantly they would
write Doctor Strange comics this comics
would last for Herald
and then they would be cancelled and so
the result was that Marvel said okay
fine let's nerve him let's listen let's
take away his powers reduce his powers
in scale and so what happened is they
created a story called the War of the
seven spheres I think and this is when
we learn that the the power the Doctor
Strange uses the various magics that he
uses are not without consequence you
can't just use them forever without ever
having to pay a price instead they're
effectively lent to him in the sense
that while it's not really said in the
beginning
somewhere along the line those
individuals who lend him this magic can
come calling favors and that's what
happened the vishanti had basically
reached out to dr. strange and said hey
we have this war going on we need you to
fight on our behalf as our avatar and is
probably gonna last a few millennia and
dr. strange said no I'm not gonna leave
the earth unprotected for a few
millennia and the vishanti said okay
fine then we're taking away your access
to your power you're no longer going to
be the sorcerer supreme now because of
this you had like brother voodoo who
basically took a spot but dr. strange
ended up coming back and becoming the
sorcerer supreme again but his power was
far less than it had been his connection
wasn't nearly as strong now there was an
in continuity reference to this and I
can remember exactly how it was they
explained it in terms of why his power
was weaker than it was before but the
fact remains that it was Marvel
basically making a way for dr. strange
to be weak it was making a way to reduce
his power so that they could actually
write some compelling stories with him
the problem is that even though he still
is weaker than he used to be he's still
stupidly powerful in terms of things
that he can do right now in this moment
he's one of the most powerful beings in
the Marvel Universe just because of the
spells that he can invoke and the kind
of things that he can do he can still
time-travel he can still you know alter
reality he can still manipulate the
powers of others he can still you know
he can steal the powers of others he can
negate the powers of others I mean it's
crazy the kind of things that he can do
right now but but again you know that's
that's more or less you know what Doctor
Strange is capable of back when he was
classic Doctor Strange he could do
anything at any point in time regardless
of what it was right now in modern
Doctor Strange he can do almost anything
that's really the kind of level that
we're talking about here it gets really
like what you start getting down to
nuances it's more or less you know what
aspects of reality can he warp and
different things like that it's just the
level of power so extreme that it's
almost pointless to say you know here
are the things
can't do because even if you run over
the things that he can't do the things
that he can do still make him a
multiversal threat so it's it's kind of
wild but anyway guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you guys are new
here to comics explain and you guys
enjoyed this video then make sure you
hit the sub button I think eyes enjoyed
this as well make sure you drop a like
and leave a comment down below cuz I'm
kind of curious what character should we
do next
on the you know strongest characters or
strong as you know most powerful beings
in comics Marvel DC valiant image
otherwise pick a character I'll go
through the list and and we'll make
videos on them at some point or another
but I didn't even we're gonna bring us
to an end and yeah I will catch you guys
later peace
you
[Music]